when people travel you know they collect
things postcards dolls and national
dress but you collect like animals like
like living animals when I don't collect
them I rescue them oh did you rescue
anything when you were in Sicily in
Tuscany not in that one but in the movie
I did right after in Bulgaria I I did
okay and I had I had promised my husband
I was gonna stop because at the time I
had ten dogs five pirates
I had alpacas horses cats and by the way
one without a tail the other one without
a leg and they always they find me they
come to me these animals which he
doesn't believe me but they do and I
promised him no more okay we were up to
thirty animals I swore no more and I was
there and a little puppy who was
abandoned and was gonna die I won't tell
you the sad circus is a comedic show and
I'll start crying he came to me and I
couldn't help and I picked him up and
his name is Ocho
after the the goalie of the soccer team
in Mexico was a welcome and I took him
and then I was terrified how am I going
to explain this to my husband I promised
I promised and so I came up with this
brilliant idea to pretend that I was
having an affair mmm sure no with
somebody to make him think I was having
an affair and at the end I would say no
it's not an affair I picked up a dog and
then you would feel better
dog this is clever
so I left him a message you must call me
at this time We Need to Talk
it's very important and I never do that
and this time is okay what happened what
happened and I said listen I feel so
terrible I don't know how to say these
to you and I know this is not not gonna
go down well and I'm really nervous and
please have mercy on me because they
should be understanding it's just it's
been so stressful and I'm so tired and I
was so lonely here many days and you
know you do crazy things when you're in
this state and he said to me oh please
don't tell me you picked up another dog
into the pump and then spray the horse's
penis with cold water better and then
the penis would just sort of go back
immediately into Oh Bart I just despise
you